do you ever watched Lex Friedman's
podcast I've seen Clips I haven't like
watched them I'm supposed to do it but I
don't think I don't think I can so I'm
gonna be in Red Rocks he has the most
thoughtful questions where he says
I'll do Alexa do a Lex Friedman question
and by the way I hope I doesn't
sometimes I say things on this podcast
it sounds like Max lives in Austin no
yeah does he really he lives in Austin
oh the one I'm gonna do his podcast when
I'm in Austin hey how about my invite
Lex yeah what the [ __ ] Lex he did a
podcast with Tim Dillon it's really good
really he did one with Mark Norman and
Mark Norman you could tell Mark thinks
he's bombing the whole time because Mark
normally bombs on podcasts but uh
but he's like he was great when he did
two bears he's like am I doing okay
um so uh
Lex Friedman this is ready okay
Tom
you don't talk much about depression but
I'm assuming you've
dealt with it as an insightful man who
has explored all aspects of his
life well read
what's your approach
to depression Jesus Lex
um you're right I wasn't expecting to go
there
you'd be good all next Freeman's podcast
he did that to Jordan Friedman Jordan
Friedman Jordan Peterson Peterson Jordan
Peterson because Jordan Peterson's dealt
with the depression I guess he's talked
about it yeah and Lex Freeman did a
great part he does great podcasts I I'm
gonna give you like not all of them are
for me like when you talk about talk to
a scientist and then elect Reuben's like
an AE scientist or something isn't he
like a AE is he but is he isn't he also
like a mathematician or something he's
Russian that's okay and he likes to
party he does well he's like I think
he's like a together guy but he does
like to party
he dude this [ __ ] gets up this
is why I like Les Friedman
he inspired what inspires you okay Tom
who
inspires you these days
I want to play a game with luxury men
things I know that you don't know and I
guarantee we never saw One Night in
Paris with Savannah Sampson
do you think Andrew huberman and Lex
Friedman would hear this and be like
these guys are fully [ __ ] R worded
foreign
I bet I guarantee you I bet both of them
look at us like we're Geniuses how so
we're not burdened with all the [ __ ]
they know they know a bunch of [ __ ] that
no one gives a [ __ ] about I wouldn't say
that no one gives a [ __ ] about us I
would say I don't care about science
well that that's what like that's why
they have followings those guys no no I
no I know that some people do right but
I guarantee you they would look at us
and be like they are totally untethered
they are not on they're not close
they're not attached to reality they're
not attached to I think they would be
like we really need to teach more
this is what's out there these [ __ ]
adults yeah
I bet we it would be like uh uh
it's like we just have a different skill
set yeah I do that that is true we have
a different skill set I have a very very
very like I bet there's things that you
talk to Andrew huberman about and he'd
be like no no like like uh tequila being
healthier than vodka he'd be like that's
actually another thing and I'd be like
well look at my recovery yeah look at my
recovery I'm in the green yeah and but I
I bet there's I bet there's things that
what could we teach them like what if we
if what if we had a TV show where we
taught lessons to brilliant people but
we we taught them our lessons
uh what were the lessons be that we
would be teaching though
uh uh Blind Faith that's it
just bet on yourself bro
and I'm black okay ready yeah think
about this no disrespect for Andrew
human and Lex Friedman okay
on paper
of course they're successful right
they're Geniuses yeah they're great as a
matter of fact I would say they're kind
of falling short of their potential in
my opinions
we have surpassed our potential this is
a really good point right yeah we're
like we're like the guy with no legs
that wins the race these guys have like
had been given grants and have degrees
and they're Geniuses find out what Lex
Friedman's IQ is I guarantee you I got
him by like 60 points
I want to take an IQ test with Lex
Friedman what's Lexie Freeman's IQ you
know he's someone who's God Like You
like he's he's done definitely taking an
IQ test probably he's probably
embarrassed about how high it is I
wonder if we can I wonder if do you
think do you think Alex Friedman if I
text him on Instagram right now he would
be like
he'd be like you know what he would do
he would he would minimize the
importance of IQ results he'd be like
well the thing is Bert IQ isn't really
that important I scored a 212.